>> All right, so what that last little exercise showed is
that XOR, in XOR parody, is hard. It's exponential. But that kind of
provides us a little bit of a hint, right? We know that
XOR is hard and we know that OR is easy. At least
in terms of the number of nodes you need, right? But, we
don't know, going in, what a particular function is. So we never
know whether the decision tree that we're going to have to build
is going to be an easy one. That is something linear, say.
Or a hard one, something that's exponential. So this brings me
to a key question that I want to ask, which is,
exactly how expressive is a decision tree. And this is what
I really mean by this. Not just what kind of functions
it kind of represent. But, if we're going to be searching over
all possible decision trees in order to find the right one,
how many decision trees do we have to worry about to
look at? So, let's go back and look at, take the XOR
case again and just speak more generally. Let's imagine that we
once again, we have n attributes. Here's my question to you, Michael.
How many decision trees are there? And look, I'm going to make
it easy for you, Michael. They're
not just attributes, they're Boolean attributes.
>> Thanks.
>> Okay? And they're not just Boolean attributes,
but the output is also Boolean. Got it?
>> Sure. But how
many trees? So it's, I'm going to go with a lot.
>> Okay. A lot. Define a lot.
>> Define a lot. So, alright, well, there's
n choices for which node to split on first.
>> Yeah.
>> And then, for each of those, there's n minus 1 to split
on next. So I feel like that could be an n factorial kind of thing.
>> Maybe. I
like that.
>> And then, even after we've done all that,
then we have an exponential number of leaves. And for
each of those leaves, we could fill in either true
or false. So it's going to be exponential in that too.
>> Hm, so let me see if I got that right.
So you said we have to pick each attribute at every
level. And so you see something that you think is probably
going to be, you know? Some kind of commutatorial question here.
So, let's say n factorial, and that's going
to just build the nodes. That's just the nodes.
Well, once you have the nodes, you still have to figure out the answers.
And so, this is exponential because factorial is exponential. And
this is also exponential. Huh. So let's see if we can
write that down. So let me propose a way to think
about this, Michael. You're exactly right the way you're thinking. So,
let's see if we can be a little bit more concrete
about it. So, we have Boolean inputs and we have Boolean
outputs, so this is just like AND, it's just like OR,
it's just like XOR, so, whenever we're dealing with Boolean functions,
we can write down a truth table. So let's think about what the truth
table looks like in this case. [SOUND]
Alright, so, let's look at the truth table.
So what a truth table will give me is,
for, the way a truth table normally works is
you write out, each of the attributes. So, attribute
one, attribute two, attribute three, and dot dot dot.
And there's n of those, okay? We did this
a little earlier. When we did our decision tree.
When we tried to figure out whether I was on a hot date or not. And then you
have some kind of output or answer. So,
each of these attributes could take on true
or false. So one kind of input that we may get would be say all trues.
Right? But we also might get all trues, except
for one false at the end. Or maybe the
first one's false and all the rest of them
are true, and so on, and so forth. And
each one of those possibilites is another row in
our table. And that can just go on for
we don't know how long. So we have any
number of rows here and my question to you is
how many rows? Go.